I'm westie I'm a seasoned battlefield
player and it's fallen to me to take
these for battlefield one novices from
corporals two generals whoa I've got
this guy like in the sniper over here
get him getting with yourself Obama okay
thanks boom out a shot
welcome to battlefield Academy
I'm Wesley for a living I make youtube
videos about battlefield oh my god no
way did I just get that kill I started
playing battlefield around bad company 2
so been involved for about five or six
years now started doing YouTube around
battlefield 3 and in at that point you
know the game was starting to get a big
following real combat in battlefield one
is for me I start this sort of style
that may be teaching people what they
can do certain weapons different play
styles and stuff like that I've pumped a
fair few hours into Battlefield games
over the years I think I probably say
over 2,000 hours into the franchise
since I started playing use the building
as cover and take me back so that's a
huge amount of time spent playing this
game knowing the ins and outs all the
mechanics how you can use the weapons
effectively how you can use the vehicles
or with your gadgets got an all-round
sort of feel for the game and how it's
moved forward over the years I'm here
for battlefield Academy now I've brought
together for people who I think could
probably do with their skills toning up
a little bit and you know they're going
to go into a live stream against the
public on launch day of battle field one
and well they're representing me and my
team so they need to make sure they're
up to standard yeah I'm Benny central
I'm a youtuber and also presenter for
Xbox on yes oh my god you got destroyed
I'm kind of being playing a lot of fat
filled one already in the Alpha be a
little bit of hands-on with the beta die
you stupid tank though not as much as I
would like oh god no but see that on
YouTube I was always a bit of a lone
wolf because I always go for gameplays
also trying to get those high scores but
then I went into competitive and kind of
had to work in a team so you learn about
communication you learn about kind of
sacrificing yourself for the rest of the
team doing the dirty work so you win the
game so I'm comfortable hopefully kind
of westie they'll be able to help as
well I think I'll curls focus on trying
to take everyone out just try to kill
everyone just I just take out everyone
that comes running through not too much
objective work
I can maybe like I love being a bit over
optimistic but it should be fun my name
is spam fish and ice cream video games
on twitch TV let's go I used to play
battlefield 2 when it first came out was
well into it then it was such a
revolutionary game at the time and
really excites check out back for one I
played a little bit but not as much as I
like and I'm excited to learn and grow
and get better today I killed someone
westie I killed someone good for you my
instinct is going to be to run and hide
and turtle but I don't think that's
gonna be good for the team so I'm gonna
go with the team i'm gonna try and
assess the situation as and when things
happen there's a sniper there's a sniper
way back by the rocks as a streamer I
kind of found myself into stream because
I quit every job I ever had I've always
had a problem with the authority of
always you know thought I know better
than anyone but when it comes to
battlefield and games out that I'm very
much you know follower I've never been a
leader or an alpha I've always been
someone that you know want to have
direction it needs to be told where to
go pray for me Wesley I'm scared of odd
the deep in is the place where you learn
to swim most effectively so I'm excited
to see how I do I've never been the
greatest player the foul fish based on
twitchtv is actually my face so I think
my reputation will perceive me somewhat
but I'm excited to learn and get better
as I say track on phone
my name is Brad I run a YouTube gaming
channel called the gaming lemon focuses
on a funny moment get fire
all-you-can-eat grenade everything all
sorta I've done a few powerful videos
not turned out extremely great because
they're not too great at the game but
I'm hoping that this all toughened me up
with a side of bad company 2 played
everyone since I've played mostly when I
can with my friends when the morale is
down off to we lose a game I try and get
a spirits back up yeah it's a simple
forget it I'm still trying to figure out
who I am on the field was my best sort
of play I think I'm quite I'm quite good
at I'm quite gonna find out the fighter
jets taking down the Bombers it seems to
be my roller man of them agree please
I'm gonna try and keep an eye office for
things that have gone overlooked and try
and fill that gap which is where
wherever I'm needed and whatever i'm a
kind of a jack-of-all-trades like well i
hope when it comes to baffle bum I you
breakfast driver I'm cam I'm one half a
common set we make gaming videos on
YouTube
both played pretty much all about feels
so far but I've never got particularly
good in my mind why am i dying while I
then okay I mean I played a lot of
battlefield 4 so I'm wondering how I'm
gonna handle going from helicopters to
horses which are quite different I think
I'm gonna be the guy running around
throwing ammo and screaming and that's
my plan and as long as i am on a horse
some part in the battle of you I got it
I hit it I didn't kill I might panic
which could be interesting so if I panic
and start getting shirty that could be
fun like supportive shorty okay yeah
yeah not like you you suck like follow
me into the gates of hell wait so if
you're losing you you get a train I'm
gonna try and be a team player but I'll
probably die quite a lot that's alright
i can be i can be the distraction throw
yes my death was not in vain
it's very interesting very intimidating
it's a bit too much like a classroom if
it was kind of authoritarian little bit
scared that Westies gonna be SAT right
in front of us I just feel like I'm
gonna be back at school kind of being
watched and observes like what are you
doing what you doing there's a big fan I
like it alright guys welcome to
Battlefield Academy you all know why
you're here you're not very good at
battlefield and you need to get better
but first of all I think we need to
establish just how bad you are so let's
get straight into it let's jump into
some matches and see what you're made up
though see this one a little bit nervous
because I'm so used to using an Xbox
controller so using the mouse and
keyboard is going to be a bit different
people are a lot more accurate than kind
of have that ability to turn turn on you
a lot quicker Wesley what where's my
control oh I'm quite lucky there I've
been a mouse and keyboard pc gaming
master race for a long time right ready
right as one we all getting this tank
it's just room force five spaces wait
he's driving this thing what are you
guys doing this little thing in the tank
waiting for war Benny I'm behind you
must go guys just right for some time oh
god I'm like I'm go down please let me
kill Doug um yeah I for some reason he
needs to help I needed shoot someone in
the sniper over here you see what I've
got a book oh my god oh my poor two
stops why did you stop I think first of
all I think I need to find out where
they all sit I'm sure they've all got
some skills hiding in hiding in the
cover there but I need to try and find
out what somebody's good out what
they're not good at and then maybe a
sign them different things so that when
they go into battle they know what their
role is we have taken objective that
okay I kind of it either go to assault
or medic because I can kind of like
getting up close and personal medic
means i'll be going in with your soul
also I solid you can't get all the
explosives and everything on that just
kinda like blowing stuff up in the sky
we go get it I think oh where the
gouache I always think I'm gonna be a
good skate and then I realize I'm not
very good with a sniper rifle so I'm
probably gonna go for the support role
so I can throw the ammo and like just
ride around on a horse and give good one
I'm gonna run the light machine gun so
if you guys scoring me I can give you a
murder thankfully I've peep around the
corner to see the reactors falling just
got crashed right into the wall I think
that this games a lot faster it's a lot
more brutal than previous Battlefield
games up close and personal like the new
movement system and the melee system is
really really cool you can get right up
in somebody's face and still get that
really satisfying kill it's this flavor
of like a modern combat scenario with a
world war one setting that's something
that I really enjoy well know him I hope
to hit the guy on the plane I just did
72 damage room nice right it's there
I've gotta boy nice good ah we need 20
points guys we need to tell that but I
was in the guy on a three way down a peg
or linux kill ya blows his head love
teach joy
I said they were quite bad to pick in
Berlin I think it was a bit harsh mayhem
drama action it was a great experience
you feel like you've been quietly judged
so you want to do the best job you can
and impress him I was quite a few times
I would be like asking a question like
how do I mark someone and then just no
answer are you happy with your roles the
worst thing is is where Steve has made
me the Scout of the team right why they
were still very good individuals but I
think we needed to work better as a
squad
play it first with EA access